thank you thank you so much appreciate
that thank you all right here we go
all right comedy look out all right
here's a here's something I noticed I
noticed that a woman wearing overalls is
always a thousand times more open-minded
than a man wearing overalls
she's a bisexual art student he hunt
squirrels from his porch like they both
still have Obama stickers on their
vehicle but with like totally different
messages now we got this new president
that's gonna look really weird
historically you know we're from a
charming black dude to a guy who always
looks like he was just upside down
[Applause]
it's about time a comedian zing that
guy's someone I'm a hero I I think I
think powdered doughnuts only exists
because at some point we needed to find
out who was eating all the doughnuts
there's gotta be like a secret purpose
you know cuz it's not even a good
doughnut
a man how's that powdered doughnut oh
it's so tri huh it's 8:00 a.m. I was
craving something dusty yeah I feel like
I feel like Boy Scouts would work harder
for their patches if their shirts were
full of holes
hey I gotta learn these knots man my
nipples are cold why is it why isn't
that scrapbooking scrapbooking it's okay
and if I do it all over the walls of my
apartment I'm too close to this case a
lot of people a lot of people think like
the middle finger is the most offensive
hand gesture and those people have never
given someone's baby a thumbs down baby
I was athletic kid growing up and still
athletic but I was fortunate I'd have
one of those like mean Little League
dads like the guys would get like way
too into it a little too critical of
their kids you know that's kind of a
ridiculous person you know like I was
raised Catholic but I don't think Jesus
came home all excited did you see that
did you see that that I rose from the
dead do you see that God's a total dick
about it doesn't take his eyes off the
TVs just like huh I saw you fell twice
I like diet Snapple enjoy diet Snapple
hi I'm a renegade I like diets now I
think I think diet Snapple should have
less interesting facts and regular
Snapple if you can't handle real Snapple
you can't handle real facts like dogs
are bigger than cats but not all the
time
I guess that's true my soap smells like
it tastes good but no ok no joke no joke
I ever write will be like as funny as
like someone falling down or a fart like
I know that I can't talk I think that's
just like all of writing I think all
writers feel that way like I bet like
Stephen King is a guy who's pretty scary
but I'm never gonna top when someone
sits on a waterbed they felt was a
regular bet alright that's my time thank
you
[Applause]